well the northern ireland protocol is an
agreement between the united kingdom
government and the eu brexit raised the
prospect of a hard border between
northern ireland a part of the uk and
the republic of ireland part of the eu
to avoid that they instead created a
trade border in the sea between northern
ireland and the rest of the uk
unionists feel that the sea border could
lead to the breakup of the uk
well let's bring in our island
correspondent david blevins who is in
belfast um and hillary ben uh was in
brussels at that meeting as the eu and
the uk government talked and he summed
it up by saying this is a standoff
that's exactly what it is again
yes and it is a battle that is taking
place on two levels because there is the
practical question around the protocol
given that northern ireland is of course
part of the uk and the republic of
ireland part of the eu how does the eu
protect its single market if there is
not a border either on this island or in
the irish sea between great britain and
northern ireland now interestingly today
the democratic unionists and the irish
government seem fairly close in relation
to how they believe this might be
resolved they're talking about a
potential landing zone referencing a
green channel and a red channel which
will sound familiar to many people who
travel in other words
goods coming from great britain into
northern ireland that are destined to
stay here in the uk would come through
agree green channel and not be subject
to checks but if they were destined for
the republic of ireland then they would
go through a red channel and have to be
checked so the practical issue is one
question the other problem of course is
the great big political right that's
taking place with the mudslinging
between the uk and the eu about who's
responsible for this you've just heard
from the cabinet minister and earlier
today foreign secretary liz trust said
they may have to take unilateral action
to override the protocol but the vice
president of the european commission
marlo sefkovic is reminding the uk that
this was the deal they agreed to this is
what he had to say
the uk has simply not taken the
opportunity to explore fully with us the
potential of the flexibilities the
commission has presented
honesty about what the uk sign up to is
needed
honesty about the fact that the eu
cannot solve all the problems created by
brexit and the type of brexit that the
uk government chose
that is the reason for which the
position of the eu has been consistent
we will not renegotiate the protocol
and the eu is united
now the reason this is all front and
center again is because the democratic
unionists are refusing to participate in
the new power sharing government in
northern ireland elected last week until
this issue is resolved there is supposed
to be the first plenary session of the
new northern ireland assembly tomorrow
we don't even know if the democratic
unionists are prepared to nominate a
speaker to even allow the assembly to
function never mind the devolved
government they're still wanting some
commitments and some action from the uk
government on this but the first
minister elect of northern ireland
shinfan's deputy leader michelle o'neill
says she will be at stormont ready to do
the business she's calling on the dup to
turn up as well and she's urging the
british government to not allow the
protocol to be used in a way that
prevents government happening in
northern ireland the british government
are playing a game of checking with the
european commission and we're caught out
in the middle because we are being held
around them because of their actions
that is not acceptable to the public
here i am angered for the public here
who want government here we want an
executive who want money in their
pockets and they want us to fix the
health service we will turn up tomorrow
to work with other parties i encourage
the dup to do likewise
so i suppose all eyes now shift to
parliament buildings of stormont
tomorrow morning to
find out if the dup are prepared to at
least put in place uh shadow assembly
while discussions continue around high
result how to resolve this very very
thorny issue of the northern ireland
protocol david thank you david levinson
with the latest